um but speaking of like other changes
that youtube has made yeah now the dust
is settled on the dislike thing yeah so
like uh has dislikes been removed i'm
very confused because i can still see
them on my channel it's it's a slow on
your channel yeah yeah yeah
yeah on anyone else's channel though it
should be completely gone no i can i can
still see it on videos i think let me
let me check let me check right now i
know i know that
yeah oh no it's gone no
no literally literally it's feeling that
for days no no i literally i literally
looked at [ __ ] videos yesterday and i
was just like where does the dislike
channel go when is the dislikes going
it was it was like it's getting like
slowly implemented i think so not all
channel owners can see it but like at
least with your own content you can
still see your dislikes which goes
completely against the argument that
youtube made as to why they wanted to
get rid of the dislikes because i
remember i made a video on a second
channel and one of the youtube's
reasonings for getting rid of the
dislike button was that like oh it you
know if you see dislikes on your videos
uh it discourages smaller creators you
know like perhaps you know they're
getting dislike bomb perhaps they're
getting bullied and no one likes to see
a bunch of dislikes
yeah you can still see dislikes on your
own videos so what the [ __ ]
you know i'm just glad they're standing
up for the small creators all two of
them or something that exists on the
entire platform of youtube um that i've
ever complained about this because like
i was talking to this about with a bunch
of other youtubers and i was i asked
them do you know a single creator in
your field that has ever complained
about disliked bombs like whatever size
yeah and not a single person i know has
ever been like
ever been like a target of dislike bombs
to the point where it actually actively
ruins their channel yeah you know have
you ever received a lot of dislikes yeah
i mean yeah for i mean because i feel me
and god make more opinionated videos
yeah right so you know obviously there
are some opinions i've said in the past
that people yeah i'm very happy with you
had a lot of dislikes on one video i've
had some videos that didn't do as well
what what what do you classify as a lot
of dislikes
more than like 10 yeah 10 is quite a lot
yeah okay yeah i've had a few videos but
not that much i don't have that much
most of it is like the mo the more
controversial opinion videos yeah um but
in general people who didn't like watch
the videos
i think the only one was the
christian one yeah yeah understandable
but uh
yeah but yeah yeah no i've had a few
where it's like it's but it you know
when i look back on those videos or like
how i presented them i can see why they
got dislike bomb and i don't really
blame them for it i guess like i
remember like i think one that really
blew up recently that got quite a few
dislikes i think it is like yeah nine to
one is uh i it's an old let's fight
episode where the title of it is uh
berserk is not a masterpiece
i think he's just like and it's like
right now i think it's like 10 years 15
and it only blew up after miura sensei's
passing right because obviously people
were searching
and obviously if you watch the video i
argue against you you'd know that joey
is like the biggest berserk simp yeah
yeah ever that was the title i used that
because that was one of the opinions i
got and i fought against it but clearly
people you know don't watch it all the
way through or up to that point so they
just see the title and they think oh
this guy hates berserk dislike in some
ways i you know i personally like the
dislike button but in other ways i think
it doesn't really do anything and it
doesn't serve
the only place you actively dislike the
video yeah yeah yeah it's definitely
okay but here's the problem right for
what reason yeah this is this is the
problem right there's no agreed-upon
consensus on when you dislike right it's
you could dislike because you disagree
with the opinion you could dislike
because you didn't enjoy the video as
much as another one you could dislike
because you just don't like the person
yeah i feel like it's the dislike
although is sometimes helpful on a
tutorial yes it's very black and white
is the tutorial not good dislike yeah
right when it comes to like your videos
i feel like the dislike bar
doesn't serve the same purpose as it
does on a tutorial where information is
actually important i i think it serves a
purpose when you know like you really
[ __ ] up you know again yeah again yeah
yeah well you've like purposely made
like a very controversial yeah yeah the
more i think about it the more i think
yeah okay in some ways the dislike
dislike on like bar is [ __ ] useless
like it doesn't mean anything it doesn't
with 99 of videos i think it's
completely useless and only with
tutorials and knowing when you [ __ ] up
that's literally the only reason well i
mean there is also some catharsis to
being able to dislike a video and just
like you see sometimes you see a video
and it's so outrageous and you want to
know that you're not the only [ __ ]
person who thinks that this video is
like this is a shitty video or something
right and you go to the dislike bar and
you're like thank god i'm not the only
one you know there is some catharsis
it's like going on to a video and seeing
comments are disabled and i'm just like
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you but that's that that's way no
balls the likes of this like bar is like
nothing it's the comments that matter i
think that and and when it comes to
disabled they get way more likely right
like to me it's like i i don't mind if
you disagree with an opinion i make on a
video but i would much rather you leave
a comment
explaining why you dislike it or why you
are against whatever i said in my video
rather than just like leaving a dislike
because
as you said a dislike can mean a million
different things because you know
sometimes people will be like this video
wasn't as good as another one does that
mean that that person disliked it and is
that is that like fair because if i
didn't like a video that someone made or
i liked another one more i wouldn't
personally dislike no i mean but that's
how i do it right so
to me trying to like extrapolate any
information from this random just metric
that doesn't mean [ __ ] like it just it
doesn't help me like when i see a video
that has 99.9 percent likes i'm like
okay now i see a video with 99.8 likes
i'm like
what's the difference here
like did they get just more likes than
previously or like less dislikes i don't
really understand yeah but i mean like i
think it is useful not in like the small
percentages but in like the large
percentages right because most videos on
youtube should have like an above ninety
percent like ratio like like to this i
think it's actually 99 it's like the is
like normally good 95 is where you're
getting to like all right maybe you've
said something like a little bad if it's
10 if you have nine to one ratio you're
probably [ __ ] up oh no you haven't
[ __ ] up you've just pissed off
my experience is you've probably pissed
off
a certain community or a certain group
you know and then you get to like the
fifty percent and that's when you know
that something big has like because your
core audience will always like that's
yeah i mean that's really but that
doesn't necessarily like for example
like you know a channel i like to watch
a lot is needle draw who does like a lot
of music reviews right yeah he's had a
couple of recent uh before the dislikes
disappeared he's had a couple of videos
that were like you know 40 likes yeah
but it was still
like a good video it was just the thing
his opinion about it obviously didn't
you know coincide with the general
public about it right so but like what
does that as a viewer what do i then
gather from that video like right i'm
like is this a bad video yeah is it does
he say something that's flat out wrong
does you say something that a lot of
people just don't agree with like it
doesn't really tell you anything it's a
mixture of all those right yeah and
that's why you have to go down into the
comments after that to be like okay what
is the reasoning behind this massive
dislike yeah yeah but like i feel like
youtube removing this way for viewers to
express themselves or like the distaste
of a video they're going to find other
ways to express their distaste towards a
video well yeah like i'm sure like
ratioing is just right
it's it's going to now be a [ __ ]
thing in the youtube sphere it's like it
wasn't already [ __ ] annoying yeah i i
can't wait to like comments to like
ratio youtube videos now because that's
just that's what's going to happen you
know it's it's
viewers always find out like audiences
always find a way to show that dislike
yeah it's either the youtube comments
are going to get more toxic or other
social media platforms that that
particular youtuber is known to be on is
going to get more toxic because like the
biggest thing that annoys me is you know
the tutorials and stuff because that you
know you are very much removing an easy
way to discern whether a tutorial is
right or whether a certain video is
right because let's say let's say you
upload a shitty tutorial or you upload a
scam right you disable comments but
likes and dislikes are still available
are still up in the open so you you're
kind of just like
you you're just kind of like taking a
risk on whether you should listen to
them right because you don't know how
many people are disabled but also likes
are very easy to manipulate as well like
that's another thing well but like the i
would argue a smaller level yeah but but
i would argue that now that you can't
even see the dislikes anymore there's
not even point of like disabling likes
and dislikes anymore right because it's
just in a constant disabled state right
because it's like you can only say like
say for example there was a scam video
yeah if they disable the comments now
what's the only thing you can see is the
likes it's like yeah i mean you can't do
anything about it because like i i think
youtube were trying to go with something
similar to what instagram did with their
likes about making like likes not public
except for the poster and like for
instagram i get it for that you know for
that platform i think it made sense
because they reverted it um they
reverted it did they yeah when i can see
all the likes reverted yeah they
reverted it yeah they reverted it since
how long like a long time now holy [ __ ]
okay
under the impression that that was yeah
yeah yeah yeah well we can see how often
god goes on instagram it's no big secret
that i don't go on instagram so uh i
guess my point is now mute
well [ __ ]
i'm glad you guys stopped me before i
was starting before i was going to start
spewing a lot of balls
no they shot for me they shot for me
yeah they're short for me
i think they might be slowly rolling it
back out or you have to like
maybe opt into it or something i don't
know but let's see okay there must be
data that [ __ ] that on their end right
that like says hey you know when people
see likes it's good for us yeah yeah i
don't know what that is i can only
probably it's probably if people can see
like it just keeps them on the platform
because
viewers want to feel like they're having
some like they can contribute in some
way shape or form well they want to see
a metric and they want to see that
metric go up with the with the youtube
one the main speculation was that brands
weren't happy with the dislike box yeah
now i'm i in some ways i feel like
that's too easy of an explanation yeah i
feel like youtube in the past hasn't i i
don't think they've been that catering
of brands
i don't know i could be wrong here i
feel like they must have some data that
backs up that removing dislikes will
lead to better views or something yeah i
mean because there's no way that you you
should youtube seems too selfish to yeah
to do something for brands it seems like
i feel like it just happens to be no so
uh so the youtube creators uh channel on
youtube made a video it's like a three
minute video that was like very concise
saying why they were moving it yeah was
it the dude who's like
uh is it the one that the guy is like
sitting there yeah the guy's just like
sitting there being like this is the
reason why we're gonna do it nice and
quick and i give him props for that at
least it wasn't like a [ __ ] 30 minute
explanation video yeah but like they
gave him [ __ ] like nick of a car yeah
exactly exactly it was nice and concise
which is nice but um yeah one of the
reasons they gave was like oh yeah we
saw a metric uh that uh we tested upon
millions of users don't know how true
that is that uh apparently the amount of
dislikes does not change uh the watch
time of that video i believe that no i
believe that yeah and i'm like yeah i
mean of course i don't you that's not a
reason though to get rid of it with
dislikes yeah exactly because i argued
being like well yeah what if you're
watching like an apology video that's
like 40 minutes long right this i'm sure
there's a lot of dislikes on it but
people want to see it until yeah yeah i
mean youtube has one priority it's
making people watch longer yeah there
must be some some evidence to prove that
i do getting rid of it makes people
watch i did find it funny though that
the last point they gave that was like
and the last question is did we get rid
of the dislike button because of youtube
rewind they brought that point yeah yeah
and dude i've never seen a guy say no
with such copium in my life
you could see how many times he had to
film that to not to like sound genuine
to like get the most genuine take that
he could
because he knew like people were gonna
be watching this under a microscope yeah
at like 0.25 speed or something to be
like well the inflection in his voice
kind of leads me to believe that youtube
made himself i heard a slight vibrato in
his voice meaning he is about to start
crying at any minute
yeah i just wish they would uh tell us
the the truth and give us some data but
they're not gonna do that why would we
no no no i mean i mean what like
what no not not annoyed me but the way
what uh
really made me suspicious was the way
they framed it to like oh we're doing
you guys a friend yeah you asked for
this
don't don't thank us later please please
hold the applause but we are helping you
for your mental health and it's just
like literally no creator i have talked
to or ever heard of like ask youtube to
do this and they framed it in a way that
they're doing it for their creativity
ever seen a youtube creator make a video
in front of the camera going guys my
mental health is deteriorating from all
these dislikes i'm getting man [ __ ] like
no of course not it's the [ __ ]
algorithm that's like demanding
youtubers to not take a break it's the
one time a corporation has said don't
worry guys we've heard you and the cr
the
the audience didn't actually say
anything
[Music]
it's literally the i've saved the day
but you haven't done anything
just leave
you're welcome i'll see ya
oh my god